joined by Florida Governor Rick Scott
from the State Emergency Operations
Center in Tallahassee good morning
governor you said something blunt on
Twitter you said the time for evacuating
along the coast has come and gone what
if I'm in the middle of evacuating and
hear that what do I do
well you've you've waited too long you
know you've got a hunker down you've got
to get shelter as quickly as you can
this thing is coming as you heard it's
getting worse I think what people didn't
realize is that could get worse 145 mile
winds down twelve inches of rain will
have flash flooding but the thing that I
think is so different is the
unbelievable storm surge we're having as
much as 13 foot of storm surge when that
storm surge comes in you have no control
of it there's so much pressure and it
pushes everything in and then it sucks
everything out 3-foot a storm surge can
be deadly so 12 13 foot of storm surge
can be devastating so we have 3,500
3,500 members of National Guard I've
deployed we have over a thousand rescue
individuals that are ready to come as
soon as this thing passes but you cannot
rescue you during the middle of this
storm don't go out in the middle of
storm and try to get somewhere we have
healthcare strike teams ready to come in
to do everything we can to help but in
right now if you're along the coast
you've got to hunker down if you're in
places like Tallahassee there's a little
bit time left but not much and we're
gonna have hurricane-force winds even in
a place like Tallahassee governor I was
looking at these I mean some of these
counties that are going to be impacted
by the storm don't even have shelters or
that the shelters that they have are
only built to withstand up to a category
two that's really scary we have 54
shelters open some of the counties like
Taylor County we don't even have a
shelter in the county because it's too
low line we are evacuation workers were
there for the for the entire county so
you know we've opened up shelters we
we're continue to open up shelters and
everything's are those shelters safe we
we work sure we work to make sure the
shelters were hoping they're safe and
we're you know we have
National Guard members there we have Red
Cross there we're going to do everything
we can to keep everybody safe but you
know we I spent you know it's so
frustrating I've spent the last two days
traveling the coast to get people to
evacuate and those that elected not to
evacuate I'm very concerned about their
safety now all right governor we are
also concerned and good luck out there
thank you